[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
Emmanuel Macron aux États-Unis pour une
visite d'État de 3 jours c'est la
deuxième pour le président français mais
la première avec Joe Biden la guerre en
Ukraine est à l'agenda et en particulier
ses conséquences économiques en Europe
mais aussi la politique de Joe Biden
qualifiée de protectionnistes par les
Européens avec notamment son inflation
rédaction actes l'Amérique de Biden
fait-elle finalement de l'America first
comme du temps de Donald Trump l'Europe
va-t-elle se vider de ses usines au
profit des États-Unis comment la France
est plus globalement les Européens
peuvent-ils se défendre économiquement
et bien dans des bas avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Thomas friand bonsoir fondateur et
directeur général de l'Institut de
l'Institut open diplomatie bienvenue à
vous en face de vous Franck de Dieu
bonsoir vous êtes directeur adjoint de
la rédaction de Marianne co-auteur de
inévitable protectionnisme et c'est chez
Gallimard dans la collection d'Emma
bienvenue à vous également merci nous
avons également avec nous Rémi Bourgeot
bonsoir vous êtes économiste et
chercheurs associés à l'Iris à Liffré ou
à l'Iris à l'Iris merci d'être avec nous
ce soir et puis en direct de Washington
notre correspondante Sonia Dridi auteur
de Joe Biden le pari de l'Amérique anti
Trump c'est aux éditions du Rocher
bonsoir Sonia
bonsoir
Emmanuel Macron est donc en visite
d'État pendant 3 jours aux États-Unis il
a d'abord rencontré Kamala Harris
aujourd'hui en présence d'ailleurs de
Thomas Pesquet et de Sophie Adnot sur la
biodiversité et la coopération spatiale
on va écouter ce qu'a dit le
porte-parole de la Maison Blanche au
sujet justement de cette visite
d'Emmanuel Macron
la France est un partenaire
international vital et bien sûr le plus
ancien allié des États-Unis nos liens
économiques s'étendent dans des secteurs
de pointe avec des investissements
majeurs dans les deux sens soutenant des
centaines de milliers d'emplois dans
chaque pays
Sonia je commence avec vous vous étiez
d'ailleurs à John Kirby qui a parlé de
Lafayette du plus vieille allié de la
mairie que représente la France est-ce
qu'on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a
une grande envie de bien accueillir
Emmanuel Macron est d'oublier totalement
cette affaire des sous-marins
oui la Maison Blanche d'ailleurs
considère que cette affaire des
sous-marins et derrière et derrière eux
que c'est une nouvelle page qui s'est
ouvert avec la France John Kirby en
effet qui s'est adressé à quelques
journalistes hier à la Maison Blanche il
nous a dit aussi ce qui l'intéressait
avec Emmanuel Macron ce qui est
intéressé les États-Unis c'est que
c'était le leader qui est c'était sa
longévité que c'était le leader qui
avait le plus de longévité au sein du
DPI du G7 notamment et donc que son
expérience était un avantage pour les
États-Unis alors il n'a pas tari des
Loges sur
Emmanuel Macron et donc on sent en effet
qu'il y a cette volonté de resserrer la
coopération avec avec la France même si
évidemment il va y avoir des sujets qui
fâchent et on en parlera mais
aujourd'hui vraiment la France est à
l'honneur et les États-Unis John Kirby
nous a aussi dit que en plus donc de la
longévité d'Emmanuel
Macron que la France avait été cette
dernière année finalement au coeur de
tous les questions de sécurité nationale
qui intéressent les États-Unis donc
c'est vraiment un partenariat important
stratégique pour Washington le président
français en tout cas veut aborder la
question du protectionnisme américain
les Américains sous l'impulsion de Joe
Biden ont adopté l'inflation Act qui
crée disent les Européens une
concurrence déloyale on va faire un
point sur ce comme on l'appelle et puis
on se retrouve ensuite
principale source de tension entre
Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden lynflation
actes sous couvert de lutte contre
l'inflation cette loi prévoit un paquet
de 370 milliards de dollars des
subventions pour permettre de
relocaliser sur le sol américain des
industries l'automobile électrique les
batteries et les énergies renouvelables
pour Bruxelles ces mesures fossent la
libre concurrence et sont contraires aux
règles du commerce international
nous avons ouvert des discussions avec
nos partenaires américains
mais je ne suis pas naïf nous ne pouvons
pas parier que les États-Unis
modifieront leur plan de manière
substantielle des inquiétudes justifiées
Joe Biden a fait de l'inflation
réduction actes le fer de lance de son
second mandat
nous fabriquons des choses ici en
Amérique et nous nous exportons à
l'étranger plutôt que d'exporter les
emplois à l'étranger comme nous l'avons
fait pendant beaucoup trop longtemps
selon Paris 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissement et 10000 créations
d'emplois sont menacés rien qu'en France
pour protéger l'industrie européenne
Bruxelles pourrait recourir à
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce mais
la procédure pourrait engager une
dynamique de guerre commerciale Emmanuel
Macron compte sur toi arracher des
exemplesions à Joe Biden comme celle
déjà consenti pour le Mexique et le
Canada mais à plus long terme la France
veut préparer sa riposte une forme de
protectionnisme européen après la Chine
les États-Unis ont basculé dans une
autre mondialisation l'Europe doit être
capable à son tour de faire cette
révolution intellectuelle face aux
décisions américaines il faut que nous
apprenions à mieux protéger et défendre
nos intérêts économiques Paris veut
appliquer une préférence aux entreprises
et aux produits européens dans les
marchés publics une vieille idée
française restée l'être morte car
contraire au principe de libre
concurrence de l'Union européenne mais
dans ce contexte elle pourrait bien
revenir sur la table
Franck de Dieu Biden fait-il de
l'Amérique a first oui et il l'assume
totalement s'il y a une forme de
continuité avec Trump mais qui était
aussi une continuité avec Obama puisque
historiquement républicain et démocrate
ont tour à tour été à la fois pour
favorable au libre-échange lorsqu'il y
avait un intérêt et puis aussi et c'est
de bonne guerre c'est pas du tout
critical ils suivent les intérêts leurs
propres intérêts nationaux ils sont
protectionnistes lorsque je dirais les
règles du jeu de la mondialisation ne
sont pas favorables à la middle America
la classe moyenne et je dirais le
président Biden a été aussi élu sur un
programme de réindustrialisation sur un
programme de retour des classes moyennes
qui avaient le sentiment d'être décroché
et c'est pour la raison pour laquelle
bien il lance une politique très
ambitieuse de trois à 400 milliards de
dollars 70 milliards de dollars
favoriser le made in America alors après
on va y revenir dire mais quelle est la
moi je trouve ça assez
étrange mais assez significatif que
Thierry Breton le premier mot qui les
prononcé il dit quoi votre portage c'est
je ne suis pas naïf parce que quelque
part les Européens ce on les a appelés
un peu les idiots du naïf du village et
bien du village global effectivement les
européens se sont montrés extrêmement
naïf avec leur politique
libre-échangiste quelque part
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
le plus moderne dans cette histoire
c'est peut-être Biden qui donne un coup
de vieux à l'Union européenne qui est
encore accroché à ses accords de
libre-échange vous êtes d'accord Thomas
friand est-ce que ça crée vraiment de la
concurrence déloyale justement à
l'Europe ce fameux inflation Act
concurrence déloyale sans doute puisque
c'est l'objet de la visite en tant que
telle et je m'inscris quasiment dans la
continuité de ce qu'il vient d'être dit
avec peut-être une nuance et que il me
semble pas qu'on puisse parler de de que
l'Union européenne sorte de sa naïve et
maintenant vous l'avez dit vous-même ce
sujet de des tensions commerciales et
les durable dans la relation Atlantique
je rappelle un simple fait c'est que
depuis 2018 les États-Unis bloquent
toutes nomination des juges qui doivent
des juges qui doivent faire fonctionner
l'Organe de règlement des différents à
l'OMC en d'autres termes ils utilisent
une forme de veto sur l'instance de
règlement des problèmes commerciaux à le
MC qui feraient que même s'il y avait
une tension qui se cristallisait de
façon judiciaire
l'organisation qui est chargée de
résoudre ce type de différents ne
pourrait pas fonctionner donc on est au
courant depuis très longtemps de l'enjeu
dans la relation transatlantique
maintenant il y a une partie quand on
connaît ce contexte géopolitique les
circonstances aussi rajout de l'huile
sur le feu c'est à dire que chaque grand
bloc économique défend ses intérêts vous
l'avez dit c'est parfaitement logique en
l'occurrence les États-Unis je suis allé
12 derniers mois connaissent une
inflation de 8% qui sera peut-être sur
la l'année 2012 supérieur à celle de la
zone euro ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est des causes d'inflation qui
sont légèrement différentes de celles de
l'Union européenne puisqu'elles sont pas
toutes aussi enchevêtrées dans la guerre
en Ukraine que celle que nous vivons
même si le prix de l'énergie
mais finalement il fait quand même une
sorte de politique industrielle
c'est un peu ça ça s'appelle un flash
and act mais on n'est pas exactement
seulement dans de la lutte contre de
l'inflation Rémi Bourgeaud justement
est-ce que vous pouvez réagir sur
exactement ce que comporte ce projet
enfin ce projet à cette loi puisqu'elle
a été votée par le Congrès donc 370
milliards de dollars pour favoriser une
production verte c'est peut-être ça la
différence entre le protectionnisme de
Biden et celui de Donald Trump parce
qu'on parlait beaucoup de America First
à l'époque de Trump parce qu'il y a des
différences
rattacher ça effectivement aux
protectionniste qui est comme vous le
disiez dans dans l'ADN politique des
États-Unis depuis le 19e siècle la relax
c'est un type de protectionnisme un peu
différent par rapport à celui de Trump
effectivement qui consiste à
subventionner assez massivement les
entreprises les ménages américaines sur
la question de la lutte enfin de
l'environnement
si une entreprise européenne parce qu'on
parle justement de l'America firs mais
si une entreprise européenne s'installe
aux États-Unis qu'elle fait de la
production donc dans l'industrie verte
elle bénéficiera des subventions oui il
sèche donc c'est au niveau local c'est
parce qu'elle doit être produite aux
États-Unis mais la société peut être
soit américaine soit européenne du
nationalisme économique pure il s'agit
de privilégier l'activité économique sur
le territoire en question sur donc aux
États-Unis et donc tous les risques de
délocalisation d'entreprises européennes
déjà dans le dans le cas des mesures
vérita en protectionnistes par ailleurs
douanière ça incite les entreprises
étrangères aussi à domicilier leur
production dans le pays en question aux
États-Unis donc c'est aussi l'idée
d'encourager non seulement les
producteurs nationaux mais les sites de
production
parce que justement dans le reportage on
voyait bien qu'on parlait peut-être de
10 milliards d'euros déjà en moins
d'investissement en France il me semble
c'était des milliards ou des millions je
peux pas dire de bêtises bref en tout
cas effectivement ça favorise des
délocalisations européennes vers
justement les États-Unis Sonia comment
est-ce que Joe Biden justifie ces
mesures ce sont des mesures donc qui
sont normalement favorables au climat
puisqu'il s'agit de la production verte
mais malgré tout c'est de l'America
feurst même si ce n'est pas l'America
force de Donald Trump
oui mais encore une fois c'est pas du
tout étonnant enfin je l'écrivais dans
mon livre avant même l'élection de Joe
Biden que s'il allait et s'il était élu
il ferait de l'America first c'était
clair pendant sa campagne en terme de
politique étrangère ou d'économie et
comme l'a dit l'un de vos invités c'est
une continuité de Donald Trump mais
surtout aussi de Barack Obama et Joe
Biden qui se surnomme lui-même middle
classe Joe donc Joe de la classe moyenne
il a promis avant son élection et bien
de travailler pour la classe moyenne
donc c'est une mesure qui est adressée
pour la classe moyenne américaine pour
créer des emplois et aussi il s'adresse
aux chicsi à la gauche progressiste
grâce à laquelle il a notamment été élu
qui voulait des mesures fortes sur le
climat et c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
une loi historique il a eu un but mandat
difficile Jo Biden et cette loi est
vraiment perçue comme un succès c'est
pour ça que aujourd'hui par exemple il y
a quelques jours il y avait un sénateur
américain qui disait un sénateur
démocrate qui disait qu'il fallait pas
s'attendre à
un miracle que la France ne devait pas
s'attendre à un geste très fort de la
part des États-Unis parce que Joe Biden
tient vraiment à cette loi par contre le
porte-parole de la Maison Blanche hier
nous a dit que quand même il la Maison
Blanche allait être à l'écoute
d'Emmanuel Macron qui va notamment
demander des exemples que le Joe Biden
qui tient à la relation transatlantique
et qui sait très bien que cette les
Européens sont sont fâchés et bien
allez on a compris que il y aurait
peut-être un geste alors on peut pas
s'attendre à un geste fort et peut-être
pas des exemples ou peut-être pas au
niveau de ce que demande les Européens
mais il nous a dit voilà que le
président serait à l'écoute et c'est
aussi intéressant parce que pour ce
sujet illustre un peu la relation que
les États-Unis ont avec la France la
France est un partenaire stratégique
pour les États-Unis mais qui est aussi
difficile parce que ils ont certaines
demandes qu'est-ce qui peut obtenir
Emmanuel Macron il me semble que il y a
un mot clé dans votre sujet déplacement
qu'on a entendu d'une toute petite
oreille qui ne semble avoir aucun
rapport qui est le mot biodiversité vous
allez me dire pourquoi est-ce que je
vous parle de ça il se trouve que votre
reporter à l'instant disait très juste
titre qu'il y avait un consensus assez
fort qui s'était forgé autour de cette
loi qu'elle s'inscrit dans la continuité
du Biden des classes moyennes qui en a
qui avait annoncé ça il avait dit je
ferai une diplomatie pour les classes
moyennes donc on peut avoir quelques
exemples sur sectoriel mais c'est pas là
où la donne va changer en revanche on
peut faire levier sur cette situation de
tension parce que ça crée un choc de
compétitivité pour les industries
européennes qui s'ajoutent au choc de
compétitif énergétique que nous
connaissons je rappelle que les
États-Unis ont substitué leur gaz au gaz
qu'on a acheté aux Russes et qu'il est
vendent trois fois plus cher
pas seulement
aux industriels américains et donc
pourquoi je parle de biodiversité parce
qu'il se trouve que la semaine d'après à
Montréal se tient la COP 15 biodiversité
que les États-Unis sont un des rares
États une des grandes puissances qui ont
signé mais qui n'ont pas ratifié la
Convention cadenations Unies sur la
biodiversité qui sont très attendus au
tournant et donc puisqu'il s'agit
d'investissement en faveur de la
transition énergétique singulièrement il
serait peut-être temps de dire à Joe
Biden vous avez toutes légitimité et on
attend fortement les États-Unis pour
être moteur de la transition énergétique
et la transition écologique parce que
c'était essentiel mais aller jusqu'au
bout du chemin faites le pas en avant
pour aller traiter pas seulement les
sujets climat mais aussi les sujets du
biodiversité parce que tout ça est
extrêmement lié et dans le paysage
américain la protection des grandes airs
naturelles est absolument essentielle je
trouve que c'était intéressant que votre
reportage mentionne ce petit mot sur la
biodiversité
Franck de Dieu ça restera très
circonscrit peut-être quelques secteurs
qui en fait je pense que pour lui le
plus difficile c'est le voyage retour
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt Washington
Paris parce que rien obtenir alors il va
peut-être tenir quelque chose mais
l'enjeu se tient à Bruxelles ou
effectivement ce que je pense c'est
qu'il y a quelque part entre les
États-Unis et en France assez
paradoxalement une sorte de génome
protectionniste qui vient chez les
Etats-Unis la guerre de Sécession ou les
Nordistes étaient plutôt
protectionnistes à les sudiste plutôt
libre-échange et puis la France qui a
une tradition où l'État précède la
nation et où l'État est interventioniste
fait des dépenses et doit favoriser au
nom d'un patriotisme économique
l'émergence d'une industrie donc quelque
part
les États-Unis et la France parlent un
petit peu le même discours la même
langue de protection en face vous avez
en revanche c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que la difficulté ça sera de
convaincre des Européens aussi de faire
une forme de protectionnisme européen
mais la difficulté c'est que quelque
part on a plaqué un peu cette histoire
française économique ou l'État était
interventionniste sur une logique très
libre échangiste très concurrentiel de
l'Union européenne et vous avez à
convaincre bien aussi les Néerlandais
qui ont je dirais une tradition
commerciale vous avez à convaincre les
Allemands qui sont je dirais très
mercantiliste vous avez à convaincre
depuis peu de temps les Pays-Bas mais
aussi des pays du Sud qui se montrent
très Atlantis donc on sait qu'il va pas
convaincre Joe Biden et en plus on pense
enfin vous pensez qu'il n'arrivera pas
alors il peut y avoir en revenant il
peut y avoir des des exceptions
notamment sur le spatial ou sur
l'énergie on pourra en parler je suis
pas spécialiste du sujet en revanche ce
que je crois c'est que ça sera la
difficulté c'est un serpent de verre ça
fait des années qu'on entend du le bail
européenne voilà bon et bien on va y
revenir ces sujets là je pense que c'est
la difficulté de ça sera la difficulté
de d'Emmanuel Macron au retour de son
voyage sur le bail mais avant cela Rémi
bonjour pour que ça soit très clair
pourquoi est-ce que les Américains font
payer aux Européens le prix du gaz trois
fois plus cher justement que
enfin c'est bien ça le rapport c'est à
dire qu'en fait on dit que les
États-Unis profitent de la guerre pour
vendre son gaz aux Européens au prix
fort pourquoi est-ce qu'il pourrait
baisser le prix du gaz parce que eux ils
disent ce sont des contrats à terme donc
on ne peut pas baisser ce prix du gaz
les Européens disent attendaient il y a
un contexte de géopolitique très dur
pour nous pourquoi est-ce qu'on paye si
cher ce gaz américain qui va remplacer
évidemment le gaz russe
de marché et c'est du du casse naturel
liquéfié donc bon il s'agit ça a marché
aussi particulier et tout le monde se
précipite donc là on est face vraiment à
une concurrence très forte dés acheteurs
qui se précipitent vers les vers les
mêmes les mêmes produits
sur la question du processus par rapport
à la relance je pense que c'est très
important parce que les États-Unis
commencent à relancer leur économie
massivement qu'ils avaient quand même
une situation plutôt de surchauffe ils
ont cette inflation très forte dans un
contexte de
d'économie quand même moins affectée
l'Europe et au premier plan de cette
crise énergétique justement vraiment en
tant que consommateur qu'importateur
d'énergie est relance beaucoup moins et
n'est pas capable de se mettre d'accord
justement du fait de ces divergences
politiques entre pays membres donc quand
vous relancez votre économie vous
relancer aussi les comics vos
partenaires commerciaux en bonne partie
et là les États-Unis relancent en gros
de leur côté et envoie le message à
l'Europe que nous on ne relance pas non
plus ils entendent profiter eux
directement et le seul de ces plans de
relance alors que leur offre elle a une
attitude plus plus passive sur sur le
plan de la relance économique donc c'est
vraiment cette divergence aussi qui est
au cœur de cette question du
protectionnisme aujourd'hui alors que
l'Europe voit son excédent commercial
plutôt fondre c'est quand même à vouloir
seulement que l'Allemagne qui avait
connu certains mois de déficit de
commerce
sur le prix du gaz les Américains est-ce
que par exemple Emmanuel Macron pourrait
obtenir quelque chose de ce côté là
puisque c'est un peu la double peine
c'est ce que dit les Européens disent
les Européens parce qu'ils ont l'Ukraine
et puis le gaz qui flambe et ils sont
obligés d'acheter du gaz américain pour
remplacer le gaz russe le geste pour
construire un peu sur cette notion qui à
mon avis est passé de protectionnisme
c'est à dire de comment est-ce qu'on
invente une mondialisation plus juste
dans un contexte de tension géopolitique
le sujet n'est pas est-ce que les
Américains doivent faire un geste
puisque les Américains n'ont pas des
prix de marché qui sont admin
le président des États-Unis
avant la guerre en Ukraine les prix du
gaz s'envolaient sur les marchés spot
sur total en avril on avait fait fois 6
assez rapidement
le président des États-Unis n'a pas le
pouvoir d'appuyer sur le bouton stop sur
les cotations des prix du gaz que ça
soit Rotterdam ou à New York en revanche
ce qui est intéressant c'est que quand
le président français pousse l'idée d'un
achat commun de gaz pour permettre les
mécanismes de solidarité entre système
énergétique européen en fait il se dit
on va mutualiser on va faire une
centrale d'achat d'énergie à l'écheur
européenne ce qu'on a jamais fait et
c'est là où si les États-Unis mettaient
des coins pour empêcher ce mécanisme
d'achat de gaz en commun et donc pouvoir
négocier des stocks à des prix qui
seraient un peu moindres alors ça ça
deviendrait bloquant donc en fait ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on pourrait attendre de
cette visite de cette manière si on
zoome spécifiquement sur le sujet du gaz
c'est que la proposition française d'un
système d'achat commun du gaz que les
marchés internationaux ne soient pas
enrayés bloqué par les États-Unis qui
chercheraient en effet là ça serait un
vrai un vrai point d'interrogation la
dynamique européenne d'absorber comme ça
vient d'être très bien décrit la crise
qu'on est en sur laquelle nous sommes en
première ligne en termes de d'impact
énergétique puisque je le rappelle
l'inflation en Europe qui va entre 7,5
et 8% pour la zone euro c'est 38% poussé
par l'augmentation des prix d'énergie a
commencé par les prix
quand justement administration Biden dit
non non on n'est pas responsable
justement de ces contrats gaziers on
n'est pas responsable de vous facturer
le gaz aussi cher c'est ce qui dit
finalement administration Biden aux
européens ils le justifie en disant ces
exportations elles ont elles sont liées
à des contrats à terme les pas question
vraiment de revenir sur un tarif plus
favorable aux Européens
oui c'est à peu près ce que ce que m'a
dit d'ailleurs hier le porte-parole de
la Maison Blanche à qui j'ai l'occasion
de poser une question et donc je vais
poser cette question pour avoir cette
réaction sa réaction alors que des
officiels européens accusent des
États-Unis de profiter de la guerre en
Ukraine alors il est il a été il est
apparu assez agacé il m'a dit que
c'était des Falls accusations donc des
fausses Falls Claes donc des fausses
d'accusation et en effet il m'a rappelé
les engagements des États-Unis envers
les Européens et donc oui je pense enfin
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui ça j'ai pas
l'impression que les États-Unis vont
faire un geste en ce sens Franck de Dieu
ce programme donc est-ce qu'il menace
véritablement l'industrie européenne sa
mobilité j'ai vu par exemple que North
Wolf le spécialiste suédois des
batteries de lithium pour véhicules
électriques envisage de construire aux
États-Unis une usine géante de batterie
justement pour profiter de cette
inflation acte donc ça veut dire que
effectivement des usines suédoises
délocaliseraient aux États-Unis c'est ça
la conséquence directe oui tout à fait
c'est l'ironie suprême de cette histoire
c'est que à partir du moment où vous
considérez que les entreprises sont
libres d'arbitrer le choix de leurs
implantations et bien elles vont très
paradoxalement pas forcément vers le
pays qui va avoir maximiser leurs profit
tout de suite mais vers des pays qui
assurent des subventions et vous avez
Elon Musk qui est aussi à renoncer à
construire une usine en Allemagne tout
simplement parce que il y avait à la
fois un problème pour écouler ces
marchandises parce que derrière cette
cet arbitrage qui est encore une fois
est assez cohérent dans un univers libre
les entreprises sont libres de
transférer leurs actifs le problème qui
se pose c'est que
si demain l'Union européenne reste
attachée à sa politique de libre-échange
et que de degrés en degrés elle voit sa
richesse économique s'affaiblir et vous
avez des entreprises qui vont dire
attendez non c'est l'effet c'est le
double effet c'est à dire que je vais
aux angles en Europe je n'ai pas de
suivants et en plus je vais prendre une
crise conjoncturelle qui va gérer mon ma
capacité à vendre mais en revanche si je
vais aux Etats-Unis non seulement j'ai
les subventions mais en plus de ça j'ai
une relance j'ai une relance économique
qui ira qui sera encore plus forte et je
vais pouvoir écouler les subventions
celui qui a pensé le premier à cela
c'est Ford donc vous voyez c'est un
américain c'est pas totalement par
hasard et bien c'est ce qui c'est ce à
quoi reste à confronté le l'Union
européenne c'est pour ça que la carte
que va jouer je dirais Emmanuel Macron
et c'est là où on pourra donner
finalement une consistance à son concept
un peu flou de souveraineté européenne
paradoxalement ce ce problème de
souveraineté européenne pourra naître
que si on va à rebours des principes
généraux qui ont présidé depuis 40 ans
c'est à dire faire une forme de
protectionnisme européen
appelant-le-fertrade appelons le non pas
droit de douane mais commerce équitable
et bien c'est vrai que c'est pour le
coup ça sera vraiment un pari mais ça
sera pas facile alors on va écouter
justement le ministre allemand de
l'économie on va voir effectivement que
c'est pas si simple de parler de
protectionnisme européen
la diversité des fournisseurs sur le
marché mondial et justement le principe
même du marché mondial il est
intelligent de la part des entreprises
d'aller vers les offres les plus
abordables pour les consommateurs le
Qatar en fait partie mais il n'est pas
le seul fournisseur sur le marché
mondial cela fait on voit bien que pour
les Allemands effectivement ils vont
acheter le gaz au Qatar sans finalement
en signifier à aux partenaires européens
ils mettent en place un plan de relance
de 200 milliards me semble-t-il sans en
parler aux partenaires européens donc
compliqué de se dire qu'on va devoir
mettre en place une politique et
industrielle ou en tout cas une
souveraineté européenne on mettait
industrielle alors que déjà on voit que
ils ne sont pas d'accord non mais vous
avez raison mais il y a un truc qui
m'interpelle c'est qu'on parle de
protectionnisme comme si il y avait une
guerre commerciale qui avait été
déclenchée c'est-à-dire comme si on
avait
le mot protectionnisme est inadapté pour
décrire ce qui se passe c'est à dire que
le protectionnisme c'est diriger des
barrières tarifaires ou normatives pour
dire vous n'entrez pas sur mon marché
c'est pas du tout ça qui est en train de
se passer
d'investissement qu'on attend de la part
des États-Unis on attend de la part des
États-Unis qui réduit qui réduisent leur
empreinte environnementale ça tombe bien
c'est exactement le sujet dans lequel
ils investissent
c'est que ça génère des effets de bord
sur notre notre industrie dans un
contexte où et c'est pas un sujet de
protectionnisme ou de libre concurrence
c'est même la vocation même de la libre
entreprise une entreprise à le droit de
choisir là où elle s'implante point
barre donc en fait les effets
d'investissement qui est en train de
créer que ça soit vis-à-vis des
européens ou vis-à-vis des Chinois ou
n'importe qui s'il dit et ben sur le
lithium quand vous investissez dans le
lithium dans la création d'une
gigafactory par exemple vous bénéficiez
d'un crédit d'impôt qui vous permettent
de récupérer 35% des coûts
d'investissement dans l'exploitation du
lithium aux États-Unis
un impact chez nous oui évidemment ça
peut avoir un impact sur notre industrie
notre capacité à produire nos propres
batteries mais ça n'est pas une mesure
protectionniste
en revanche ce qui est important de
souligner c'est que dans cette
concurrence là et ce qui est ce qui est
problématique c'est que les mécanismes
par lesquels on pouvait créer une
synchronisation des plans de relance
budgétaires et monétaires des grandes
économies mondiales qui s'appelle le G20
et à minima avant même plus d'Europe
de coordination des plans de relance et
on l'a vu avant même la guerre en
Ukraine quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
accélère pendant que quelqu'un qui
freine en économie ça génère des effets
de distorsion qui sont inflationnistes
même l'inflation au moment où la guerre
en Ukraine commence elle a déjà commencé
parce que précisément ces mécanismes de
coordination macroéconique budgétaires
et monétaire sont dysfonctionnel
qu'importe le que ça soit un Allemand le
commissaire breton ou le président
français qui le disent ce qui est un
fait c'est qu'on ne parle pas de
protectionnisme c'est que les mécanismes
de coordination économiques sont
dysfonctionnel et nous-mêmes on doit en
tirer nos leçons vous l'avez dit à très
juste titre si nous avions le même plan
d'in investissement en Europe avec des
mêmes niveaux de d'investissement
à la hauteur de la situation d'avoir à
l'échelle européenne un plan
d'investissement massif dans les
technologies qui vont favoriser la
transition énergétique alors il y a un
plan sur les batteries par exemple voilà
donc là il y a des subventions là on
peut dire qu'il y a des subventions
européennes pour un plan batterie par
exemple des programmes européens là
quand même ce qui aux États-Unis ce qui
ont qualifié de protectionniste c'est le
fait que ce soit conditionné à l'achat
de produits américains comparant les
ménages américains sur subventionnés
pour acheter des produits américains
donc c'est assez quand même rattaché à
une forme de protectionnisme ce que les
Européens ont du mal à faire au final on
chacun
en Europe lorsqu'on subventionne on
oblige pas d'acheter européen par
exemple c'est ça la différence alors pas
européen et surtout la crainte c'est que
il y a des sors entre États ensuite par
exemple il y a d'autres distorsions qui
sont créées quand l'Allemagne
effectivement a mis en à ce plan de
soutien de subvention des coûts
énergétiques pour les entreprises
allemandes ça crée un écart de
compétitivité et ça énormément inquiété
les gouvernements européens avec l'idée
que l'Allemagne s'embarquait à nouveau
dans un dans une stratégie d'abaissement
de ses coûts aux dépenses de ses
partenaires commerciaux européens pour
se repositionner commercialement et
redéployer son excédent commercial donc
on a un énorme problème de coordination
en Europe effectivement dans les plans
de subvention les plans de relance on
est beaucoup moins
effectivement et même Emmanuel Macron
qui demande tous les deux qu'il y ait
justement un plan européen une sorte de
même acte mais en Europe donc on y est
on est très loin de ça on est très loin
de l'idée de ce type de protectionnisme
on est très loin de ce niveau de
coordination entre gouverneur européen
surtout on voit effectivement
l'Allemagne qui a sa propre stratégie
une stratégie générale d'abaissement des
coûts pour se repositionner
commercialement ce qu'elle a fait dans
les années
le coup du travail en déployant ces
chaînes de production en Europe de l'Est
et là elle essaye de se poser parce
qu'elle voit une explosion un doublement
de ses coûts énergétiques en gros elle
essaye de réduire la facture pour pour
les entreprises donc on a aussi au sein
dans la coopération européenne la norme
problème de coordination et des pays qui
tirent les choses aussi à leur avantage
pourquoi est-ce que c'est si compliqué
alors que ça serait dans l'intérêt de
tous alors 27 États c'est peut-être trop
c'est compliqué parce que si vous voulez
le le choix d'une politique si vous
voulez pas l'appeler protectionnisme
effectivement on pourrait je veux pas me
lancer dans une querelle byzantine
savoir si des droits de douane c'est pas
pareil que les subventions ces
différents que des des considérations
normatives etc c'est que ce pourquoi
c'est très difficile en Europe c'est
d'abord parce que ça suggère soit
l'unanimité soit la majorité qualifiée
de d'État qui n'ont pas à court terme du
moins les mêmes intérêts alors que
l'Union enfin que les États-Unis c'est
une nation à part entière et puis
d'autre part que ça va à rebours d'un
logiciel qui de d'un logiciel qui a été
mis en place dans les années
70-80 de l'Union européenne qui ne
voulait pas qui croyait à la libre
concurrence de façon dogmatique c'est en
ce sens que la grande différence entre
les États-Unis l'Europe on l'a souvent
dit c'est pas forcément que les valeurs
soient différentes c'est que il y a une
forme de pragmatisme à l'instant T
c'est-à-dire que au fond les les
Américains peuvent être quand ça les
arrange et encore une fois à bon droit
d'être favorable au libre-échange mais
les Européens sont sur des positions qui
sont doctrinales qui sont idéologiques
il faut absolument considérer que c'est
une concurrence déloyale vous avez posé
la question d'abord vous avez dit est-ce
que c'est de la concurrence déloyale
mais qu'est-ce que c'est de la
concurrence loyale est-ce que le fait de
d'être de mettre en concurrence salariés
de la classe moyenne français avec des
des salariés qui sont payés très très
peu cher c'est de la concurrence
déloyale ou c'est de la concurrence
loyale normalement il y a l'OMC qui est
censé vous en avez parlé à très juste
titre c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
le l'instrument qui qui manque et qui ne
marche pas on l'a vu aujourd'hui avec
l'OMC on l'a vu hier avec la cop27 c'est
que le multilatéralisme n'existe plus
mort et donc dans ces conditions-là et
bien il n'y a rien d'office même
européen du même nom
et bien c'est le bilatéral qui prend le
dessus et dans un point de vue il faut
attendre quelque chose quand même de
cette rencontre
parce que je sais que vous devez nous
quitter là dans une minute donc je
voulais juste vous faire intervenir
encore une fois est-ce que justement
dans cette conférence de presse est-ce
qu'on parle de ce buyeux Pen Act est-ce
que finalement les Américains verrai ça
plutôt d'un bon œil ou d'un mauvais œil
alors je suis pas sûr
qu'il verrait ça forcément d'un bon œil
mais en tout cas oui la presse
américaine en parle beaucoup que c'est
l'une des contre-mesures que le
président Macron devrait mettre sur la
table ce bail American Act je pense
aussi qu'un autre sujet dont on parle
beaucoup même en relation avec ce cette
loi ira c'est peut-être un moyen de
mettre sur pression sur l'administration
Biden pour le président Macron c'est
aussi de parler de la Chine parce que
l'un des alors une source officielle ici
à Washington disait aussi que la France
va aussi dire à Biden que oui les
Américains aimeraient que les les
Français est une et les Européens en
général mais notamment les Français une
position plus dure envers la Chine ou un
naïf ou un naïf comme disent parfois les
Américains mais et bien en contrepartie
il faudrait peut-être pas trop affaiblir
le Vieux Continent l'Europe avec ses
mesures qui sont considérées
protectionnistes donc par les Européens
en plus de la montée du prix du gaz donc
je pense que un moyen de faire pression
pour pour les Français sur les
Américains ça va être aussi de de mettre
la Chine au cœur au cœur des discussions
merci beaucoup Sonia Sonia Dridi donc en
direct de Washington est-ce que
effectivement ça fait voir partie un peu
du bargain ça parce que les Chinois
effectivement investissent encore en
Europe et pas vraiment de
protectionnisme à l'égard de la Chine et
là aussi l'Allemagne a une vraie
politique industrielle avec les Chinois
elle ne prévient pas d'ailleurs ses
partenaires européens et Olaf Schulz
étalé à Pékin sans justement soutien
sans le soutien être d'Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'effectivement on va se
retrouver peut-être dans un espèce de de
marchandage avec les Américains en
utilisant justement ce sujet chinois
vous avez quelque part deux couples qui
se mettent en place là c'est la ce que
de jouer la diplomatie française c'est
de se dire regardez nous rapprochons des
États-Unis au nom d'une concurrence
loyale du libre commerce entre deux pays
qui finalement ont les mêmes
caractéristiques économiques et sociales
à peu près et puis vous avez le
l'Allemagne qui fait cavalier seul et
qui pour garder des parts de marché
auprès de la Chine va se compromettre
avec une un pays qui n'est pas
démocratique effectivement ce qui se
joue en fait moi je reviens à
l'expression
inflation reddition Act c'est quand même
intéressant parce que quelque part on
nous a vendu que le Made in China les
consommateurs français il y avait un
intérêt parce que ça faisait baisser les
prix et toutes les logiques déployées
dans les années 90 ou 2000 pour dire
finalement vous avez un intérêt à la
mondialisation peut-être que ça crée de
la désindustrialisation mais votre
pouvoir d'achat il augmente parce que
vous pouvez acheter du made in China
beaucoup moins cher et bien l'expression
revient aujourd'hui un petit peu quand
même revient et regardez ce je dirais ce
retour de d'appréciation et compte tenu
dans le mot inflation réduction actes
c'est-à-dire que on marche sur la tête
on va faire une politique
protectionniste qui était change
supposée créer de l'inflation et on va
l'appeler c'est au contraire une manière
de réduire l'inflation alors bien sûr il
y a quelque chose d'assez politique le
fait de se dire je fais de la
protectionnisme parce que l'inflation
vous allez avoir non seulement on va
faire du protectionnisme en fait vous
allez avoir une réduction de l'inflation
ce qui se passe et ce qui remet en cause
la politique de mondialisation qui a été
largement avalisée par l'Union
européenne c'est quoi c'est que la
mondialisation hier elle suggérait de la
baisse des prix aujourd'hui on importe
de l'inflation et c'est ça qui
évidemment change complètement le regard
que l'on doit porter sur la
mondialisation et son contraire la
diémondialisation
qui qui est vraiment ce qui est censé
réduire l'inflation et il Marissa
effectivement ce qui est intéressant à
une forme de protectionnisme mais il ne
voit pas ça comme comme une forme
d'antagonisme d'avoir
un antagoniste
on lui-même qui est censé non plus
réduire l'inflation mais effectivement
on a on a une rupture avec le pays de
communication aussi Thomas friand est-ce
que effectivement on atteint une sorte
de est-ce qu'on rentre un peu dans une
période de démondialisation mais est-ce
que l'Europe a du mal justement à s'y
mettre à du mal cette bail your pen Act
par exemple est-ce qu'il verra un jour
le des jalons déjà très forts sur ce
chemin là elle est pas totalement
a obtenu à l'échelle mondiale une
taxation minimale des entreprises je
veux dire la fiscalité mondiale ça fait
des années lumière
française de l'Union européenne il y a
pas plus tard que six mois donc ce
mécanisme il a été acté il va commencer
à être mis en œuvre là pourrait nous
attaquer si c'était mal calibré pour
protectionnisme devant l'OM c'est pour
le coup parce que là pour le coup on a
vraiment des barrières tarifaires alors
je moi je suis considère que c'est un
acte parfaitement sain au regard de
objectifs en matière de transition et
aux métiers au regard des grands
équilibres j'ai économiques qu'il faut
recréer mais la pseudo naïveté
européenne qui serait supposée être
ancré dans une forme de dogme
libre-échangiste à Bruxelles ça fait au
moins 5 ans qu'on a tourné la page
depuis que depuis excusez-moi monsieur
depuis que Donald Trump a déchiré le
communiqué de du G7 de Charlevoix en
2008 en 2018 pardonnez-moi c'est à dire
depuis le moment où les États-Unis
bloquent toute nomination et le MC qui
permet de Ré régler les différents ça
fait un bon moment que l'Union
européenne est sortie de sa naïveté
quand on fait quand Marguerite vestiger
qui est la vice-président de la
Commission européenne chargée de
l'ensemble des questions de concurrence
inflige des sanctions monumentales qui
chiffre en milliards de dollars à Google
précisément parce qu'il ne respecte pas
les règles fiscales internationales
voilà je veux dire les gestes que ça
soit des gestes individuel ciblés sur
des entreprises qui sont des loyales que
ça soit des gestes politiques sur la
gestion de nos frontières ou que ça soit
des gestes d'ordre d'ordre normatif sur
les règles du jeu de la fiscalité
internationale sur l'ensemble du spectre
l'Europe mais aujourd'hui les Européens
ont peur de la délocalisation des
entreprises européennes aux États-Unis
malgré tout les Européens et l'Union
européenne vous là où il y a je suis un
d'accord avec vous c'est sur un aspect
très précis c'est que depuis l'élection
du chancelier Scholtz on voit une sorte
d'échappée sauvage parce que le modèle
économique allemand qui était fondé sur
les relations commerciales privilégiées
avec la Chine un appareil industriel
financé à Bakou par des prix d'énergie
extrêmement faibles liées au gaz russe
et toute une chaîne de valeur liée dans
les pays de l'Est de l'Union européenne
ce modèle économique est en train de
s'effondrer à cause de la guerre Ukraine
en d'autres termes mais il le défendent
toujours bah ils vont essayer le
défendre et pour cause c'est la vitalité
de leur économique qui est en cause et
dans d'autres termes là où je suis
d'accord c'est que d'une certaine
manière le grand la fin de cette visite
c'est le chanceler seul ce qui va
entendre parler à moult reprise d'un
sujet dont il ne veut pas entendre
parler c'est la façon dont on va gérer
nos achats communs à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne alors que ça fait six
mois qui fait cavalier ça je pense que
je vais vous rappeler dans ce conflit
commercial quand même l'Europe a une
position très largement excellente
depuis depuis longtemps sur les
États-Unis et dans la le front qu'a
ouvert
Donald Trump face à la Chine juste
derrière venait la question de l'Europe
et l'Europe ça restait abstrait abstrait
sur le plan commercial évidemment il
s'agit de l'Allemagne donc l'Allemagne a
défendu une politique très libre
échangiste mais à sa façon en
développant une stratégie qui lui était
américaine
avec ses règles de de commerce mondial
libre en abaissant les coûts les coûts
du travail les coûts énergétiques en
développant des chaînes de production
labyrinthique à échelle mondiale qui
aujourd'hui sont en grande difficulté
donc on a deux modèles différents avec
l'Europe de son côté et sous l'Allemagne
qui a développé un énorme excédent
commercial et notamment sur les
États-Unis donc c'est le contexte de ce
conflit là et les Américains essaient de
de reikiwan sur la façon et n'y sont pas
parvenus par exemple avec la Chine les
mesures Donald Trump ont été assez
largement de protectionnisme sur le ce
qui est
commercial américain n'a été que
croissant en fait au cours de ces années
vous réagissez justement vous venir
parce que par rapport à la noyalité
effectivement il y a une c'est pas il y
a une certaine clairvoyance aujourd'hui
de l'Union européenne sont plus naïfs
ils sont plus naïfs comme ils étaient
auparavant effectivement mais à vrai
dire ce qu'il faut ce à quoi il faut
s'intéresser c'est aux résultats
c'est-à-dire que le diagnostic de la je
dirais de la guerre commerciale des
limites du libre-échange il a été fait
sauf que quand vous prenez toutes les
mesures qui ont été citées par
particulier ce qui concerne le droit de
douane sur les taxes carbone aux
frontières etc à chaque fois vous avez
pour des raisons qui sont
consubstantielles aux institutions
européennes le plus petit dénominateur
commun qu'il en porte et y compris aussi
sur la règle fiscale c'est-à-dire qu'on
est pris du gaz mais au bout d'un moment
quand vous êtes très nombreux et que il
faut obtenir un accord soit la majorité
qualifié soit uneanimité et bien vous
érez vos ambitions de départ et vous
finissez par produire quelque chose qui
je dirais est annoncé avec tambour et
trompette en disant formidable ça y est
le rendez-vous de la dernière chance
l'Union européenne enfin trouvé la
parade etc elle n'est plus naïve comme
auparavant et en vérité quand vous
regardez concrètement les modalités de
ce réveil commercial de l'Union
européenne vous apercevez que et bien
c'est une grande déception à tous les
égards Thomas friand sur la déception et
on termine là pour moi c'est pas un
sujet commercial à nouveau c'est la
seule différence que j'ai de fond c'est
qu'on n'a pas une politique
d'investissement comme on a eu au moment
du couple Macron marque après le sommet
de mes orbergs où il y avait
effectivement cette idée et la
commission la reprise d'un
[Musique]
la crise covid qui n'est pas terminée
c'est la crise la crise ukrainienne
merci beaucoup Thomas fried en avoir été
avec nous merci à vous Franck de Dieu
merci Rémi bourjo et puis merci à Sonia
Dridi qui était avec nous pratiquement
tout au long de cette émission en direct
de Washington merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi restez avec nous sur France
[Musique]